well we've been assessing on a daily
basis the time at which we would secure
successful outcome on a vote of
no-confidence because what we want to
achieve is an outcome rather than it
just being a little bit of parliamentary
drama theatrics if you like now what
we've seen over the last week or so has
been an absolute shambles we were
supposed to have a vote on the Prime
Minister's deal last week it was pulled
at the 11th hour because she knew that
she didn't have the support within
Parliament that said she known for over
two weeks that she didn't have support
within Parliament for that deal and
rather than trying to renegotiate or
reach out to members across the house as
to what steps could be taken next to
make that a deal around which there
could be a parliamentary consensus she
dug her heels in and and left it right
up until the eleventh hour before she
took action now the problem that we've
got within Parliament is because it
didn't get negotiated discussed within
Parliament
Tereza May was in the dark essentially
as to what the different problems and
concerns at various parliamentarians had
about the deal so she went off to the
European Union to seemingly seek
assurances which wasn't entirely sure
what she was seeking assurances on she
knew that the backstop was a problem
well she hadn't even entertained any of
the other issues that many of us across
the house have had with the deal the
fact that it doesn't provide a strong
direction in terms of our continuing
single market relationship the fact that
it didn't deal with security issues the
fact that it really didn't keep up with
European Union standards on consumer
rights protections environmental
standards for example so we really are
in in quite a precarious position at the
moment and what we're doing certainly
from the Labour Party's perspective is
pushing the Prime Minister to bring that
deal to Parliament next week so that we
can have that discussion at the
beginning the answer you said that you
didn't want to have the confidence
though in the government until you're
sure what the outcome would be but you
don't just get one shot at it you can
have a go and then you know have another
go after Christmas for example if it
doesn't work out so I just don't really
sound why you wouldn't seize the
momentum and that the opposition has at
the minute against Theresa May and run
with it I mean if you're being cynical
you might suggest that actually labour
doesn't really want to take over the
brakes
oceans because it's far more easy
criticizing from the comfort of
opposition well don't think it will be
sensible or pragmatic to hold a vote of
no-confidence set every single day
within Parliament knowing that we are
going to lose that vote of no-confidence
I think there's a lot more that needs to
be done within Parliament the
government's taken its eye off the ball
on domestic policy for example we're
supposed to have the NHS 10-year plan
and we've heard very little we're
supposed to have the response to the
Taylor review on employment rights and
practices and we've heard nothing about
that there's various different domestic
policy matters that need to be dealt
with
urgently and we don't want to take up
parliamentary time unnecessarily
but what we are doing as I say is
speaking to various parties across the
house and assessing the time at which
there would be a successful outcome on a
vote of no-confidence but what we want
to see straight away this week is a
debate on Tereza Mays deal and the
opportunity for members across the house
to put forward their concerns so that we
can reach a consensus because I believe
that there is a deal that Parliament can
coalesce around I believe that you know
the Labour Party set out its negotiating
principles a strong customs union deal
that would arrive for Britain to have a
say in future trade deals a strong
singing it mark single market deal a
floor under existing rights and
protections and environmental standards
and workers rights but not only that
guarantee that we will go beyond the
minimum floor that the European Union
has set and we think that there would be
support support within Parliament for
that but we're not being given the
opportunity to put those options on the
table at this time one thing that many
MPs believe that there would be support
in Parliament for is a second referendum
I know that Labour have conflicting
opinion shall we say about whether
that's the best way forward what do you
personally think would you like to see a
second referendum well late labor policy
is not conflicting we've been very clear
that we want to secure a deal that puts
our economy and our communities first in
the communities amazed deal well in that
well I'll just set out what the labour
party position is first so in terms of
our party busy what a fantastic
discussion about this at conference and
we set out that if to resume couldn't
pass a deal within Parliament she
refused to read ago she ate she refused
to call a general election
then all options would be on the table
to avoid an Odile situation and that
would include a public vote as well but
that's not put in any particular
hierarchy we would assess that in line
with any other options that are on the
table at that time in terms of my own
personal position I think we need to
respect the referendum as I say I think
that there is a deal that can be struck
within Parliament that brings everybody
together that respects the views and
wishes of communities whether they voted
leave or remain and I think as MPs
across the house we have to do
everything within our power to secure
that now in an extreme situation if that
is not possible
I share the position that our party has
set out that we have to keep all options
on the table and that we wouldn't rule
out a people's vote at some point I mean
you must have looked at some of the
polling numbers and know your
constituency is pretty divided really
when it comes to brexit do you think
that having a second referendum as party
policy would help or hinder Labour's
chances at a general election well it's
not about whether it will help or hinder
the Labour Party this is what it you
know he's doing the right thing
essentially and you know we had a
referendum people spoke quite you know
vociferous ly and passionately about you
know leave and remain and we've got to
respect those views and concerns and as
parliamentarians we have got to do
everything within our power to secure a
deal it doesn't leave us in a worse
economic position but also respects the
result of that referendum now in the
event we can't secure that we have to
examine all the options but I don't
think we're at that point yet we've seen
a complete shambles in the way that the
government has dealt with negotiations
over the last two years red lines that
they've set out that the European Union
thinker are quite simply preposterous
even Teresa Mae went to it's--you're
this week stating that she wanted help
and she wanted to seek assurances but I
think as I said earlier they weren't
even sure what she was seeking
assurances on and so you know we really
do need to see more work and more
collaboration across Parliament and and
I really do worry that if we don't see
that deal being discussed within
Parliament this week and being voted
upon then we really are you know working
against the clock you're talking there
about Teresa mains reception in Brussels
I'm interested to get your thoughts of
the actions of the president of the
Commission jean-claude young Co you must
have seen that video of him you know
tussling that woman's hair and rather
bizarre Nana
he was then forced to deny calling
Teresa may nebulous he then said it was
all ok because they she was kissing him
afterwards do you think that he would
have treated her in that way if she was
a man well I don't think you know
dealing with people in that way or or
being nasty you know as part of
negotiations and I'm not saying that
that's occurred but you know it as a
general principle is right whether
you're a man or a woman and I wouldn't
like to hazard it you know any kind of
presumptions that you know he's done
that because Teresa may is a woman if he
has then that's absolutely diabolical
but you know I think we treat you know
our negotiating partners with respect
and I think when you do that then you
end up with a good outcome to those
negotiations we've not seen that in
negotiation so far we had the Prime
Minister standing on the steps of
Downing Street threatening a few months
ago stating that Britain was preparing
for no deal trying to push the European
Union into a position and that's not to
say that the European Union have been
exemplary in their negotiations either
and I think what we do need to see is
everybody behaving a little bit more
calmly and negotiating with respect